Vale Rivera former leader of citizens
has resigned after he was made
1 letter or 1 touch of attention
from the law firm
on which I was working
telling him that he was
eh practicing at very low performance
that it was not meeting the established requirements
that he was not contributing any work
and that therefore
his work was exaggeratedly insufficient
for the level that buffet had
he who has been offended
has resigned and I think it is 1 Good eh reflection
of how meritocracy is important in this country.
not how there are certain characters
as Mr.
Albert Rivera
who gets jobs
very good for 1 merit which is meritocracy
which is neither due
and then as some politicians
do not understand that when they stop being politicians
and they stop having that smile
have to return to their normal jobs
instead of being on the rotating doors
and some of them
when you are among their normal jobs
do not have the recognition and even the
sufficient willingness to do the job
like normal people
we make 1 more sample
that there are politicians
who do not understand what it is to work
and that the only thing they wanted
was to have a lot of money